tout de suite notre second débat comme
chaque soir vous le savez cette semaine
il est consacré aux conséquences de la
guerre en Ukraine un an après l'invasion
russe on tire les leçons du conflit ce
soir sous l'angle de l'eau capacités de
défense en France et en Europe on
commence par détailler l'effort
militaire réalisé pour soutenir les
soldats Ukrainiens avec Fabien rekker
des soldats Ukrainiens équipés de
lance-missiles Javelin une arme livrée
massivement par les Américains depuis le
début du conflit selon le décompte d'un
institut de recherche allemand
Washington a déjà annoncé plus de 46
milliards de dollars d'aide militaires à
Kiev très loin devant l'effort des
Européens et en particulier des 700
millions d'euros d'aide militaires
mobilisés par la France Paris a
notamment fournit 18 annonces Césars à
l'Ukraine et vient d'annoncer la
livraison de 12 canons supplémentaires à
la conférence sur la sécurité de Munich
Emmanuel Macron a appelé ses alliés à
poursuivre leurs efforts nous devons
absolument intensifier notre soutien et
notre effort
pour aider à la résistance du peuple et
de l'armée ukrainienne et leur permettre
de mener la contre-offensive qui seule
permettra des négociations crédibles aux
conditions choisies par l'Ukraine ses
autorités et son peuple mais Paris
hésitent toujours à fournir des chars
Leclerc à l'Ukraine notamment pour ne
pas affaiblir ses propres stocks une
hésitation que ne partage pas le
Royaume-Uni deuxième plus gros
contributeur à l'effort de guerre
ukrainien et premier pays à annoncer des
envies la livraison de charlourd
challenger à Kiev en troisième position
l'Allemagne c'est déjà engagé à hauteur
de 2,4 milliards d'euros après une
longue hésitation Berlin a finalement
annoncé la livraison de Charles lourds
léopard à l'armée ukrainienne des
européens engagés mais toujours
réticents à fournir les avions de combat
pourtant réclamer par l'Ukraine
la priorité aujourd'hui c'est le
matériel terrestre c'est celui dont les
Ukrainiens ont le plus besoin dans
l'urgence face à l'offensive russe la
livraison d'avions de combat c'est
beaucoup plus complexe pourquoi parce
qu'il faut former des pilotes donc
aujourd'hui l'urgence et le matériel
terrestre et dans un deuxième temps la
question bien sûr de la reconstitution
d'une flotterienne au profit de
l'Ukraine se posera rapporter à leur PIB
le plus gros effort de soutien à
l'Ukraine est fourni par les pays de
l'Est de l'Europe en tête l'Estonie qui
investit plus d'un pour cent de son
produit intérieur brut pour soutenir
Kiev devant la Pologne qui joue aussi le
rôle stratégique de plaques tournantes
c'est par son territoire que transit
l'ensemble des équipements militaires
fournis à Kiev par les Occidentaux
général c'est le titre de ce second
débat je vous présente mes invités
général Dominique Trincant bonsoir
bienvenue ancien chef de la mission
militaire française auprès de l'ONU
Christine Dubois Clément bonsoir et
bienvenue cherche en géopolitique pour
la chair risque de l'IAE Paris
implantéon Sorbonne Cédric bonsoir vous
êtes sénateur du Territoire de Belfort
vice-président de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées et puis co rapporteur de
ce rapport d'information Ukraine un an
de guerre quelles enseignements pour la
France qui vient d'être publié Mathilde
Sirault évidemment est resté avec côté
éditorialiste pour sens public on va je
vais commencer par l'actualité ce on va
parler des armes nucléaires depuis que
vous le savez la Russie a annoncé hier
suspendre sa participation traitée
newstart qui alors on va donner quelques
chiffres limites la puissance nucléaire
des États-Unis et de la Russie un
maximum de 1550
ogives et 800 lanceurs et bombardiers
lourd hier Vladimir Poutine a donc
annoncé
enfants dans la participation de son
pays on l'écoute et puis juste après la
réaction du secrétaire d'État américain
antonymeinken
sur la Russie
l'annonce par la Russie de la Suisse
pension de sa participation au programme
new starte et très décevante et
irresponsable nous surveillons
attentivement ce que la Russie fera
réellement nous ferons en sorte d'être
quel que soit la situation dans une
position appropriée pour la sécurité de
notre propre pays et de nos alliés
2050 ça veut dire quoi cette suspension
est-ce que c'est une forme de menace
nucléaire
sous-entendu brandit de lumière Poutine
ou pas non pour moi c'est pas du tout
une menace nucléaire c'est simplement
des accords dans lesquels il y avait
possibilité de vérifier de part et
d'autre où on était le plafond qui était
qui était prévu et bien il n'y aura pas
de vérification mais il n'y avait plus
de vérification de toute façon donc je
pense que c'est une déclaration qui n'a
pas d'effet immédiat qui veut simplement
faire parler du nucléaire dans cette
guerre c'est ça veut faire parler et au
passage on en parle beaucoup à l'ouest
dès qu'on
anime le mot nucléaire tout le monde en
parle et tout le monde panique un petit
peu à juste titre parce que le nucléaire
c'est quand même très dangereux mais
ceci étant je crois pas que ça fasse un
changement majeur d'accord Cédric
Perenco comment comment il faut réagir
justement parce qu'on
générale quand même expliqué les petits
jouent avec nos ports nucléaires quand
il fait ça comment il faut réagir
écoutez moi je crois que de ce point de
vue là et depuis le début de la guerre
en Ukraine en février l'année dernière
je pense que sur le sujet nucléaire il
faut aussi faire de la pédagogie sur la
grammaire du nucléaire je pense que tout
ça c'est un jeu aussi de de de
dialogue et surtout tout ça doit être
compris comme étant quelque chose qui
est extrêmement codé et je pense que les
choses se comprennent d'une partie à
l'autre et qu'il faut pas y attacher non
plus une importance plus importante que
ce qu'elle veut bien avoir je crois que
le discours de Poutine avait
essentiellement pour vocation à
s'adresser à sa population essayer de
remonter
euh le moral des troupes si je puis dire
et essayer de mobiliser en Russie la
population derrière derrière le
j'allais dire dictateur d'air Poutine et
voilà sur la sur le nucléaire je
continue d'insister sur cette grammaire
je pense qu'elle est importante qui a
des codes et que le fait qu'ils annonce
ces choses comme il le fait
pour comme le disait le Général quand à
l'instant pour objectif évidemment de
rappeler que cette question du nucléaire
elle est toujours sous-jacente dans ce
conflit elle est extrêmement présente
Christine Dubois Clément il y a eu aussi
alors c'est peut-être une coïncidence
mais il y a eu de la part de la Russie
un test de missile longue portée juste
avant la visite de Joe Biden à
Kiev mais alors c'est intéressant parce
que tout comme les États-Unis ont
prévenu la Russie finalement Joe Biden
passait à Kiev la Russie avait prévenu
les États-Unis qui aurait ce test de de
missile intercontinentale bah c'est pas
si étonnant que ça parce que notamment
quand on parle du traité qui qui vient
d'être déchiré vous avez des inspections
donc effectivement qui ont été suspendus
en Russie depuis cet été ce qui avait
valu un rapport aux vitriol et très
sévère de l'administration américaine en
janvier mais vous aviez aussi les
annonces des des exercices des tirs
d'exercice ça avait été le cas quand il
y a eu par exemple un tir d'un sarmat en
avril de l'année dernière là en fait
c'est celui-ci voilà
ça si vous voulez avec cette suppression
là ce que vous faites aussi dans cette
espèce de parliez de grammaire du
nucléaire de jeu de la dissuasion vous
allez un petit peu manipuler le flou etc
alors certes à l'étranger mais aussi en
interne où vous mettez en avant la
capacité de puissance et donc une
projection de puissance vous n'allez
plus déclarer quand vous allez faire des
tirs d'exercices ce qui vous permet
aussi potentiellement de mettre un petit
peu de un petit peu de pression et
potentiellement de gesticulation ou
dissuasion en fonction de ce que vous
allez faire
ce que j'ai lu et pour et d'ailleurs
s'il n'avait pas échoué on peut imaginer
que le dire en Poutine on aurait parlé
dans son dans son discours et il ne l'a
pas fait donc effectivement c'est un
c'est un signe allez toute cette semaine
vous savez on dresse le bilan de cette
année de guerre et donc là on va se
concentrer sur la défense défense
française défense européenne 2030 en
terme de stratégie militaire quel est
pour vous le changement le plus profond
la leçon principale à tirer de cette de
ces 12 mois de conflits alors la
première leçon en tirer c'est que les
dividendes de la paix ont été une
catastrophe pour notre défense pendant
25 ans tout gouvernement confondu les
budgets de la défense ont baissé dieu
soit loué les armées ont essayé de
maintenir alors on parle d'armée bonzaï
d'armée échantillonnaire un échantillon
un peu de tout pour être capable de
remonter en puissance et depuis 5 ans le
budget a augmenté là il y a une nouvelle
loi de programmation qui sera présentée
cette année donc tout ceci pour nous
français et la prise de conscience que
l'effort de défense doit s'amplifier
doit continuer mais plus loin que ça
pour les Européens je crois qu'il y a
une leçon majeure c'est que
globalement on sait au sein de l'OTAN
qu'on s'oppose à la Russie donc c'est le
temps mais je suis frappé dans les
rencontres que j'ai avec beaucoup de
pays européens dans lequel on pourrait
avoir peur en disant ça y est le temps
efface l'Union européenne on en parle
plus et en fait pas du tout les pays
européens disent
oui c'est le temps on y va avec le temps
et tout on peut pas s'embêter
ça nous permet de nous renforcer nous
Européens et si les Américains venaient
à changer d'avis à un moment donné sur
la une défense de l'Europe et ben on
aura quand même fait des progrès donc je
crois que c'est vraiment un sursaut à la
fois au sein de l'OTAN mais aussi les
Européens sachant que la France avait
pris un petit peu d'avance en ayant
anticipé par la loi de programmation qui
est en train de se terminé et que les
autres pays se sont réveillés il y a un
ou deux ans à peu près Christine Hugo à
Clément on a dû revoir la hiérarchie des
menaces ça je trouve ça intéressant je
voudrais vous entendre là-dessus
si vous voulez ce que l'on avait eu
parce que quand vous allez faire une loi
de programmation militaire et que vous
allez structurer vos armées avec
notamment le matériel nécessaire et bien
vous le faites en vue de répondre à une
menace ou une menace que vous allez
estimer comme étant les plus probables
donc vous allez faire une hiérarchie des
menaces et il se trouve que et bien on
avait une hiérarchie des menaces qui
estimait que le risque principal était
notamment d'origine terroriste et
exogène et que bah du coup on avait
moins de possibilités d'avoir une guerre
dite de haute intensité sur le
territoire depuis maintenant de
décennies et du coup on a constitué une
armée sur des corps beaucoup plus
expéditionnaires ce qui avait un sens
donc après on peut on peut le discuter
mais il y avait une cohérence à ce
niveau là et que l'on a structuré
beaucoup de choses comme cela la
meilleure preuve c'est que quand la
Russie démarre son invasion il y a un et
bien tout le monde est un peu sidéré de
retrouver une guerre de cette nature là
avec deux armées qui s'affrontent de
manière traditionnelle avec le retour de
l'artillerie de la haute intensité sur
le territoire européen et là on voit
qu'on est obligé de changer les choses
donc on va changer notamment le braquet
et la structuration donc vous avez tout
cela qui va venir en ligne et puis
derrière ce que vous disiez aussi donc
même si on avait pris un petit peu
d'avance de voir comment est-ce que on
conçoit l'armement quelle nature
d'armement l'autonomie
et ça prend du temps et voilà et l'enjeu
c'est ça c'est que ça va prendre du
temps parce que vous avez par exemple
des industries de défense qui avait une
un type de production qui doit remonter
de manière assez rapide donc ça veut
dire des chaînes de montage donc ça veut
dire des savoir-faire et effectivement
il faut du temps et puis vous êtes avec
quand vous discutez avec du tissu
industriel ben il leur faut des
commandes enfermes et des fonds pour
commencer à redémarrer principalement ce
qui peuvent pas le faire à fond perdu et
dans le vide en suspension on y
reviendra un peu plus en détail sur le
le évidemment le le l'industrie de
l'armement en France mais est-ce que ça
veut dire que notre armée elle est plus
elle n'est plus adaptée à la nouvelle
menace aujourd'hui ce qui vient d'être
dit tout à fait exact et j'aurais pas pu
le dire le contraire on est on a
j'allais dire dimensionner une armée
pour des guerres choisies et aujourd'hui
on est dans des guerres qui sont des
guerres suivies on a évidemment vécu des
dividendes vécu des dividendes de la
paix et moi je ne veux jeter la pierre à
personne parce que je pense que
l'objectif quand même de tout un chacun
c'est de gagner la paix et gagner la
paix c'est aussi dans une période qui
était celle que nous avons vécu après la
chute du mur et après à la fin de la
guerre froide et bien une période où on
a pensé que la paix était éternelle et
que la croissance était infinie et on ne
peut jeter la pierre
d'augmenter le budget de la défense
c'était parfaitement intenable mais je
pense que les objectifs étaient
peut-être différents et on a cru à des
choses qui malheureusement
se sont effondré le 24 février dernier
et aujourd'hui nous allons devoir faire
face à des guerres qui sont des guerres
subies dans lesquelles effectivement on
est plus dans des conflits asymétriques
avec des des conflits avec des groupes
armés terroristes mais avec des États et
les choses changent pour que la menace
terroriste elle a pas totalement
disparue non
c'est ce que nous rappelons dans le
rapport que nous venons de rendre au
Sénat sur la nécessité d'avoir
évidemment un équilibre entre le
l'aspect conventionnel l'aspect
nucléaire et de d'essayer de de gagner
en masse et et et en volume de de de de
munitions de matériel et autres et ça
c'est quelque chose de particulièrement
important et qu'il faudra mettre en
oeuvre il faut moi c'est ce que je dis
depuis le début on va avoir dans les
jours qui viennent dans les mois qui
viennent à discuter de la loi de
programmation militaire et ce n'est pas
le budget qui doit faire la stratégie
mais la stratégie qui doit faire le
budget or aujourd'hui la stratégie on ne
la connaît pas vraiment la revue
stratégique qui a été définie l'an
dernier par le Président de la
République n'avance ou quasiment aucun
élément sur cette question et donc ce
que nous attendons nous la
représentation nationale c'est qu'il y a
une discussion très claire sur sur ce
sujet le budget a été annoncé maintenant
il faut définir il faudrait peut-être
qu'on nous parle de la stratégie c'est
plutôt on aurait sans doute d'ailleurs
commencé par ça comment l'Europe
peut-elle mieux protéger ses habitants
de de d'une menace extérieure question
évidemment fil rouge de ce débat je vous
propose tiens d'entendre le secrétaire
général de l'OTAN James Stoltenberg qui
forcément met en avance on organisation
écoute
aujourd'hui un an après nous pouvons
déjà tirer quelques leçons la première
est que nous devons soutenir l'Ukraine
les alliés de l'OTAN ont fourni à
l'Ukraine un soutien militaire d'un
niveau sans précédent nous devons
continuer et maintenir notre soutien
l'autre leçon que nous pouvons tirer et
la nécessité d'investir dans notre
sécurité même si la guerre prenait fin
demain elle a modifié notre
environnement sécuritaire à long terme
le président Poutine veut une autre
Europe il veut une Europe où il contrôle
ses voisins et nous devons donc
continuer à investir dans notre sécurité
je voudrais rester sur cette dernière
phrase Cédric Perrin le prix en Poutine
veut une autre Europe il veut une Europe
où il contrôle ses voisins et nous
devons donc continuer à investir dans
notre sécurité est-ce que Vladimir
Poutine tant qu'il est au pouvoir est-ce
qu'on doit considérer le géant russe
comme une menace pour nous
pour nous directement peut-être pas mais
il y a un certain nombre de pays qui
sont des pays qui ont vécu de 50 années
très compliqué avec avec la Russie qui
sont avec moi d'ailleurs à l'Assemblée
parlementaire de l'OTAN et qui depuis un
certain temps effectivement nous annonce
un certain nombre de choses d'autres
qu'on a parfois pris avec avec légèreté
peut-être parce qu'on a considéré que
dividende de la paix oblige les choses
n'arriveraient jamais ils pensaient à la
Pologne par exemple on soit l'Estonie à
la Lituanie au Pays Basque à la colonne
pourquoi pas qui sont des gens qui sont
à la frontière russe et qui craignaient
cette cette folie russe et finalement
elle est arrivée aujourd'hui la
nécessité c'est évidemment de travailler
en collaboration avec l'ensemble des
pays européens mais de ne pas être naïf
non plus c'est à dire que le temps et je
suis j'étais rapporté en général la
commission sécurité Défense de
l'Assemblée parlementaire de l'OTAN je
je j'ai une vision assez
j'allais dire
ça reste un outil de domination
économique des Américains sur l'Europe
aujourd'hui on voit bien l'utilité de
l'OTAN de l'interopérabilité mais ne
soyons pas naïf on a besoin au niveau
européen de développer une industrie une
industrie de la défense qui soit
efficace dans laquelle nous nous
entendions nous entendons l'exemple des
chars Abrahams qui risque d'arriver
peuvent parfaitement mettre en
difficulté de manière très très
importante le projet de char du futur
mgcs qu'on veut faire avec les Allemands
militaire sur le sur le terrain des
opérations vous diriez que là sans
l'OTAN le cours des choses aurait été
difficile
auraient été différente
a montré sa réactivité je rappelle que
la France était en pointe puisqu'elle le
fournissait la CAP force de réaction
rapide de le temps donc elle a tout de
suite marqué sur le terrain
sa position et il est certain que la
Russie dans cette agression qu'elle fait
sous parapluie nucléaire elle protège
par sa dissuasion le territoire russe
mais en revanche et la Grèce son voisin
donc l'Ukraine et face à cela il y a
bien sûr les Européens mais les
Américains et on voit bien que la
confrontation États-Unis Russie et la
confrontation majeure de puissance
nucléaires qui équilibre un peu les
choses pour répondre simplement à votre
question je pense que la Russie n'est
pas notre ennemi mais en revanche et je
me réfère sur Poutine est au pouvoir
voilà parce que je me réfère au discours
du président Poutine celui-là et celui
qui l'a fait dans un sage Saint-Georges
le 30 septembre et celui qui l'avait
fait avant clairement lui il déclare la
guerre à notre civilisation en clair
notre façon d'être notre façon donc
c'est lui et c'est pour ça que je parle
du du régime de Poutine et non pas de la
Russie le problème c'est que la Russie
étant une dictature il y a pas beaucoup
de russe qui s'exprime beaucoup contre
ce que dit le président aujourd'hui où
les oppositions ont été écartées et donc
on voit pas très bien qu'elle pourrait
être la réaction de la population
par rapport au régime de Poutine mais en
tout cas régime de Poutine clairement il
déclare la guerre lui
Christine ou Clément quand même c'est je
parlais citer la Pologne enfin en citer
d'autres pays c'est pas la même chose
d'attaquer l'Ukraine que d'attaquer la
Pologne puisque la Pologne ils ont
longtemps on l'a beaucoup dit il faut il
faut peut-être le rappeler quand même
dans là on est en train de se de se
placer dans une configuration
stratégique on dit la Russie tant que
Poutine est au pouvoir pourrait si on
l’arrête pas aller plus loin et envahir
d'autres pays est-ce que vous y croyez à
ça alors qu'il y a longtemps comme
bouclier pour la Pologne par exemple il
y a effectivement l'OTAN comme comme
bouclier alors ce qui est pas
inintéressant c'est de regarder que
finalement la pratique agressive que
l'on a de la Russie ne date pas de
février elle date même pas de 2014 où
marathon les annexions de ce que l'on a
eu tout cela d'ailleurs en ayant quand
même signé des traités où il s'engageait
à respecter l'intégrité territoriale et
là souveraineté d'un État sur lequel on
est parti sur un principe d'invasion bon
on peut en reparler mais on a eu déjà
d'autres cas où on a eu de la
déstabilisation où on est rentré sur des
territoires etc et on a joué quand même
du moins la Russie a joué de manière
régulière à essayer d'aller un petit peu
toucher les limites si vous voulez et
marcher sur la ligne rouge et de voir
quel serait les réactions notamment des
pays des pays membres de l'OTAN ce qui
avait d'ailleurs donné des tensions mais
vous connaissez ça beaucoup mieux que
moi vous diront dans des discussions
animées entre les pays d'Europe de l'Est
qui disaient attention attention les
autres qui disaient oui mais vous êtes
hyper réactif quand les autres disaient
oui mais vous êtes averti faux risque si
on va de manière un petit peu un petit
peu rapide on a aussi subi et on
continue de subir au Mali enfin quand
Wagner arrive on Centrafrique quand il
va amener arrive au Mali quand Wagner
arrive au Burkina Faso c'est aussi test
de la capacité de la France à réagir or
on n'a jamais rien dit comme être clair
oui et qui se met qui sont qui sont plus
tardifs
en 2014 et l'arrêt orientation mais je
pense que si on avait eu des réactions
différentes peut-être que les choses ont
également été différente simplement sur
le
l'agressivité de la Russie vis-à-vis de
l'OTAN moi je regarde simplement un
rapport de force c'est sans aucun
ambiguïté la Russie ne peut pas
s'affronter à l'OTAN elle a déjà
beaucoup de mal à grignoter 20% du
territoire ukrainien en étant obligé de
mobiliser 300 000 hommes en plus voir
500 000 s'affronter à lointain c'est Noé
comme dirait les Américains
à quoi ça sert ce faut-il se réarmer à
ce point si vous nous dites
sera jamais s'attaquer pour maintenir
comme comme le dit le chef d'état-major
de la mettait aujourd'hui nous nous
défendrons demain nous nous défendrons
mieux c'est tout c'est il faut
rééquilibrer remettre
[Musique]
des troubles sur différents territoires
où vous allez être engagés ce qui
participent à finalement tout simplement
ne vous empêcher de vous concentrer sur
un point parce que vous en avez
plusieurs à gérer potentiellement
et c'est ce que vous avez et c'est ce
que vous voyez à l'heure actuelle très
clairement où vous allez jouer sur et
bien agiter alors certes des endroits où
il y a un terreau fertile vous allez
jouer sur des mécontentements locaux
alors et sur des discours qui peuvent
survivre à leur plus ou moins en petite
foulées depuis plusieurs années derrière
vous allez avoir un enjeu économique
aussi et ça faut pas l'oublier c'est à
dire que si vous arrivez à essayer de
gagner des marchés en perdre d'autres la
capacité de projection de puissance d'un
état et de maintenir elle est aussi par
rapport à son pouvoir économique donc
vous pouvez vraiment jouer sur
différents niveaux sur un temps court
moyen et long et le volet informationnel
ça vous coûte finalement pas très cher
et vous pouvez c'est très difficile à
endiguer alors l'Europe de la défense
elle a du mal à s'imposer Mathilde
faudrait peut-être que nous français on
se remette en question
en communication Thomas quand un message
a du mal à passer on peut se demander si
le problème ne vient pas tout simplement
de l'émetteur en l'occurrence sur le
sujet dont on parle il s'agit de la
France l'Europe de la défense le
programme européen de sécurité de
défense l'autonomie stratégique vous
l'appellerez comme vous voudrez ce sont
des idées des concepts impulsés par la
France rappelez-vous du plan Fouchet à
l'époque du général de Gaulle en pleine
guerre froide qui a finalement échoué en
1962 on se souvient de Michel
Alliot-Marie en 2003 qui s'enthousiasme
devant la progression de l'Europe de la
défense alors qu'on en est qu'il y a des
petits pas beaucoup de déclarations de
bonnes intentions mais peut suivi des
faits en réalité la France a toujours eu
du mal à convaincre et à embarquer sur
ce projet commun comment on peut
l'expliquer
alors l'Union européenne bien sûr est
d'abord un projet économique des
obstacles culturels demeure quant à une
meilleure intégration militaire en tout
cas hors temps de guerre l'Allemagne et
la Pologne pour nos citer que c'est deux
pays sont davantage atlantistes les
intérêts aussi divergent évidemment la
France a pu parfois paraître solitaire
dans cette croisade pour une Europe de
la défense parce que aux yeux de
certains états la purée opportuniste où
tout du moins soucieuse de faire
profiter sa propre industrie d'armement
au détriment évidemment de celle des
Américains Paris a ensuite eu beau jeu
d'encourager des États à accroître leurs
dépenses en matière de défense puisque
la France pointait encore à la fin de
l'année dernière à la onzième position
loin donc de pouvoir donner l'exemple
sur ce sujet le président français
peut-il marquer des points obtenir des
avancées victoires politiques sur ce
sujet Emmanuel Macron a fait de la
défense européenne on le sait le faire
de lance de sa présidence de l'Union
européenne l'année dernière il y a eu
des progrès on pense
à la boussole stratégique la France veut
rester moteur mais il manque encore des
relais Emmanuel Macron paraît parfois
isolé il est même accusé par certains de
vouloir affaiblir l'OTAN au profit de
l'Union européenne et en disant ne pas
vouloir écraser la Russie ou ne pas
vouloir humilier la Russie il braque
aussi parfois de potentiel parties
prenantes notamment à l'est de l'Europe
ces derniers jours ces dernières
semaines c'est l'Estonie qui s'est
toutefois engagée par la voix de sa
première ministre qui appelle la
mutualiser la production de munitions et
les achats de pièces d'artillerie sur le
même modèle de que ce qui avait été fait
pour l'achat de vaccins au moment du
covid un projet qui en réalité est en
discussion depuis un an mais en cale
minée au Parlement européen merci
beaucoup Mathilde Dominique trinquant
quand on parle on en fait dans ce débat
un peu le bilan de ce que les leçons
qu'on peut tirer de ces 12 mois il y a
eu quoi un accélération quand même
système de cette idée d'une Europe de la
défense et moi je parle de la défense de
l'Europe plus que
moi je pense qu'il fallait et je pense
que il y a eu une accélération
extraordinaire vous parliez du projet
qui dure depuis un an un projet sur
lequel j'ai beaucoup travaillé la
facilité européenne de paix ça a été
discuté pendant des mois des années
c'était quoi c'était un de l'argent qui
était mis pour équiper en fait à
l'origine essentiellement des pays
africains et d'autres pays et là dedans
les Européens à discuter j'avais pas
dire du sexe des anges mais du fait
qu'on pouvait donner de l'armement létal
ou pas on en discutait depuis un an et
demi et en 48 heures on a décidé de le
problème a été débloqué donc il y a une
accélération fantastique et sur
l'interpénénération c'est pour ça que je
passe de la défense de l'Europe sur
l'interpénétration entre l'OTAN et
l'Union européenne je vous donne un
autre exemple le projet de transport
stratégique à travers l'Europe il se
trouve que moi j'étais officier
opération du deuxième corps d'armée en
Allemagne en 90 donc à l'époque on était
face pack de Varsovie on savait très
bien manœuvrer tout en Europe puis on a
complètement oublié pendant 30 ans et là
le 30 portes stratégique c'était un
groupe de travail de l'Union européenne
et qu'est-ce qu'a fait le temps elle a
demandé bah écoutez si vous pouvez nous
donner les résultats ce serait pas mal
pas les résultats parce que je crois que
c'était pas abouti mais si on pouvait
rentrer dans ce dossier là ça serait pas
mal donc ça c'est quoi c'est pour
transporter juste pour bien comprendre
le lieu où elles sont produites et et
c'est aussi simple exemple très pratique
pour transporter les chars Leclerc de
France en Roumanie on n'a pas pu le
faire par la route parce que les normes
allemandes s'y opposées qu'on a pu le
faire par le chemin de fer alors
normalement si opposé autrefois on
connaissait tout ça par coeur on
appuyait sur un bouton de l'ordinateur
et on vous disait par où il fait passer
et tout ça ça avait été oublié donc je
crois qu'il y a une accélération
fantastique il y a sûrement beaucoup de
progrès à faire on parlait des munitions
les normes européennes qui empêchent de
fabriquer des sous-ensembles en Europe
parce que écologiquement c'est mauvais
pour la santé des gens alors il y a
plein
je pense qu'il faut je pense qu'on n'est
pas dans le monde dans le dans le bon
débat c'est à dire que un moment donné
il faut expliquer ce que c'est que la
défense européenne parce que je pense
que pendant la présidentielle de 2017 et
malgré le Macron a dit des choses qui
ont complètement faussé le débat parce
que on a cru ou en tout cas les
électeurs qui ont voté pour lui pas moi
ont cru que on allait avoir des soldats
avec un drapeau européen et un casque un
casque aux couleurs du drapeau européen
c'était pas ça la défense européenne ce
que nous voyons enfin ce que moi j'entre
autant comme défense européenne c'est
une coopération industrielle en matière
de défense c'est-à-dire une coopération
entre les pays européens pour être
meilleur pour être capable d'innover
davantage pour être capable de mettre
beaucoup plus d'argent pour faire un
système de combat aérien du futur
l'avion du futur qui pourrait coûter
jusqu'à 50 milliards de d'euros de
développement être capable de le faire
ensemble or aujourd'hui on y arrive pas
parce que et je pense que la situation
est encore plus grave avec la guerre en
Ukraine parce que le fait aujourd'hui
que les Américains reviennent en Europe
avec du matériel va forcément nous
pénaliser et il y a au niveau européen
des forces contraires il ne faut pas se
cacher derrière son petit doigt il y a
au niveau européen par exemple des
Allemands qui voudraient que ce soit au
niveau européen qu'on contrôle les
exportations d'armes il y a au niveau
européen des gens qui insistent pour que
par exemple le la BITD ou en tout cas
l'industrie de la défense ne soit plus
financée parce que c'est mal de financer
la guerre il faut se le dire quand même
et aujourd'hui il y a encore des
entreprises aujourd'hui c'est un
problème de plus en plus important que
les entreprises vivent au quotidien
parce qu'au niveau européen vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure sur l'énorme en
matière environnementale il y a des gens
qui continuent à nous expliquer qu'il ne
faut pas financer la défense donc il y a
évidemment des avancées mais il y a
aussi énormément de force contraire qui
font qu'aujourd'hui nous n'arriverons
pas à travailler ensemble et puis il y a
aussi il faut le dire des pays européens
qui continuent d'acheter américain au
détriment du matériel européen alors ça
ce sont évidemment des freins qu'il faut
arriver à lever je ne suis pas sûr
qu'aujourd'hui le président de la
République est la crédibilité suffisante
pour y arriver malheureusement mais en
tout cas c'est quelque chose que RK il
faut tendre de manière urgente
nous considérons les allemands comme des
des partenaires un couple comme étant un
couple franco-allemand eux disent qu'on
est des partenaires on n'a pas du tout
la même approche des choses l'Allemagne
essaye et c'est pas un secret de
reconstituer une industrie de la défense
qui est la perdue sans doute après la
deuxième guerre mondiale elle y arrive
de manière extrêmement bien mais pas
suffisamment pour avoir toutes les
compétences donc on n'a pas toutes les
mêmes demandes la France voudrait avoir
du matériel qui soit opérationnel pour
pouvoir aller faire des opérations donc
on n'a pas les mêmes logiques donc il
faut qu'on arrive à travailler ensemble
c'est ce que je pense tout le monde
essaye de mettre en oeuvre mais c'est
très difficile à Clément votre avis
là-dessus l'Europe on l'a rappelé c'est
d'abord une organisation économique donc
effectivement c'est sur le plan
industriel qu'il faut qu'il faut
travailler prioritairement vous allez
avoir plusieurs éléments alors après
quand on parle des industries vous allez
vous retrouver dans ce qu'on appelle de
la coopétition vous vous allez être en
coopération parfois et en compétition
sur d'autres donc ce qui facilite pas
forcément le travail notamment sur sur
des technologies complexes il y a un
point aussi moi qui me paraît
intéressant peut-être si vous ne
permettez à lever si on prend cette
année il y a deux éléments qui me
semblent importants on a une nature de
la guerre qui a changé parce qu'elle est
beaucoup plus transparente d'un point de
vue tactique notamment parce que
maintenant vous avez une capacité
notamment de surveillance avec de
imagerie satellites ce genre de choses
et une montée en puissance des nouvelles
technologies et notamment tout ce qui
est technique de l'information et de la
communication qui fait que vous voyez
assez rapidement ce que va faire votre
adversaire dans le cadre de des
Ukrainiens ils ont aussi bénéficié d'un
soutien de différents services de
renseignements occidentaux qui leur ont
permis ce genre de choses donc vous avez
un enjeu de rapidité qui est de dire ce
que vous allez faire ça va être visible
donc il faut que vous puissiez agir
avant que l'autre puisse contre carré
donc ça on a une certaine forme de
transparence qui est quelque chose que
l'on n'avait pas préalablement et qui
vient notamment parce que on a une une
augmentation de la capacité
technologique donc ça c'est un point qui
va falloir rentrer finalement en plus de
est-ce qu'on retourne sur des guerres de
haute intensité ce qui n'exclut pas
d'autres risques dans la hiérarchie des
menaces c'est pas forcément un
remplacement c'est on complète donc
comment est-ce que l'on fait comment
est-ce que on va transparence des
informations qui sont accrues vous avez
une forme de transparence tactique si
vous voulez à ce niveau-là et la
deuxième chose c'est que on parle
d'industriels donc de grosses machines
industrielles vous avez aussi une
capacité d'innovation et de disruption
qui va se faire un petit peu beaucoup
plus par le bas alors on va le voir
notamment sur les petites entreprises
des startups
si on parle notamment de tout ce qui va
être encore une fois technologies de
l'information ce sont des lignes de code
vous avez beaucoup de logiciels ouverts
donc vous pouvez commencer à les créer
et quelque part des industriels vont un
petit peu potentiellement pouvoir courir
derrière vous avez aussi une autre
question la vue les Ukrainiens ont été
particulièrement agiles là-dessus et
réactif alors vous allez me dire ça
démarre pas depuis un an ça fait 9 ans
qui sont quand même aux prises avec avec
ce conflit que nous on redécouvre
oui bah quand vous êtes dedans quelque
part la nécessité fait loin encore une
fois où vous allez avoir notamment quand
on a parlé des drones on a beaucoup
parlé des bailleurs mais vous avez aussi
des petits quadricoptère qui ont été
adaptés par la société civile avec des
gens qui avaient des compétences et qui
ont une prise directe avec un retour
avec des unités qui leur permet
d'adapter d'améliorer alors évidemment
vous allez pas être sur un prédateur ou
sur autre mais dans la façon dont vous
allez l'utiliser sur quelque chose de
très agile et sur quelque chose qui est
du domaine du consommable les drones
auxquels je pense sont en dessous de
20000 dollars il y a cette question là
je voudrais quand même dire quelque
chose parce que je suis le seul sénateur
je voudrais dire que tous ces points qui
sont évoqués là sont des points que nous
avons dans des différents rapports à la
commission soulever depuis quelques
années j'ai fait deux rapports sur les
drones j'ai fait un rapport sous
l'innovation en soulevant exactement ces
points là et je trouve que finalement
nous sommes dans la nous sommes dans
dans la dans la vraie vie et nous
constatons au quotidien les problèmes
que nous que nous rencontrons et que
nous armures rencontres et c'est le
problème lactique elles sont en tout cas
par défendre recommandations traitées
dans des rapports que fait le Sénat fait
la commission de l'affaire étrangères de
la défense et j'invite chacun à s'y
référer vous me m'offrez la transition
sur proposer à Quentin calmer de nous
rejoindre parce que justement Quentin on
va parler de ses rapports revançoire
alarmant consacré au stock d'armes dont
dispose de la France oui tout à fait il
y a total pas moins de trois rapports
parlementaires qui ont été commis comme
on dit c'est Damien semaine sur le sujet
devenu de l'Assemblée nationale et un
autre réalisé pas à dessinateur dont
vous donc Cédric P1 dans ce livre
dessinateur déjà on fait la liste par
exemple très intéressante Thomas la
liste précise de nos équipements les
plus importants ceux qui sont
disponibles pour l'armée française la
France dispose ainsi de 222 Charles de
combat 18 systèmes solaires et 253
avions de combat à comparer avec ce qui
ce jour Ukraine même si comparaison
n'est pas raison que les situations les
pays sont très différentes mais regardez
par un point en un an voilà ce qui a été
détruit sur le champ de bataille la
Russie l'Ukraine en respectivement déjà
perdu
1642 et 449 Charles de combat 88 et 86
thèmes solaires et 69 et 56 avions de
combat et donc les parlementaires sont
très prudents sur le niveau de
préparation de la France en cas d'une
guerre de haute intensité le rapport
sénatorial appelle ainsi à des
engagements ferme de l'État en termes de
commande ils veulent aussi relocaliser
certaines productions stratégiques comme
par exemple les poudres propulsives et
aussi constituées des stocks
stratégiques tout en renouvelant le
stock existant cela pourrait être fait
notamment à l'occasion du plan
d'investissement de 400 milliards
annoncés par email Macron sur la période
2024 2030 Thomas et alors les députés de
leur côté ils se sont concentrés sur les
les stocks de munitions et sur les
moyens de défense solaire exactement là
en terme de munitions les députés
parlent d'un niveau préoccupant des
stocks français depuis la fin de la
guerre froide et jusqu'aux attentats de
2015 la France a subi une logique de
réduire massivement les budgets
militaires et en particulier les
munitions et qui restent ainsi ces
députés la France doit constituer un
stock voici un extrait de leur rapport
le retour d'expérience du conflit
ukrainien illustre ainsi les multiples
atouts stratégiques que recèle la
constitution de stock de munitions
l'impératif de reconstitution des stocks
militaires et d'ailleurs un constat
partagé par de nombreux pays occidentaux
et Christ ainsi Vincent brut et Julien
rancoulent là encore l'État doit assurer
de la visibilité et de la régularité aux
entreprises de cette économie de guerre
selon eux et enfin a joué terminé avec
l'autre constat celui sur la défense
solaire dans le rapport de Nathalie
pouziref et de Jean-Louis Thériault ont
lit ainsi cette phrase en temps de
guerre Thomas dans le cadre d'un conflit
de haute intensité on estime que le
nombre de missiles tirés par jour sur le
territoire ennemi peut s'élever à 200 la
défense
en face à ce tir d'intensité n'est
aujourd'hui pas à la hauteur on voit
donc que la guerre en Ukraine a changé
la donne la hausse des budgets de
l'armée était amorcé depuis le 2019 faut
maintenant tirer les enseignements de ce
qui se joue à l'est du continent sans
pour autant calquer nos investissements
sur ce qui s'y passe Thomas merci
Quentin cette information qu'on a reçu
en cette fin d'après-midi de nos
confrères de l'Agence France Presse
annonce du ministre des Armées Sébastien
Lecornu le la France va relocaliser la
production de poudre pour obus Christine
Dubois Clément je vous vois réagir il
était temps en quelque sorte ou en fait
c'est des questions qu'on s'est posées
alors avant d'arriver sur les
problématiques d'armement sur la
capacité d'assurer tout ce qu'on va
payer la Supply chaîne dans tout votre
chaîne d'approvisionnement de produits
de matière première pour déjà maîtriser
vos coûts maîtriser pardon vos
approvisionnements et avoir une capacité
de réaction et d'autonomie et il est
évident que pour certaines industries ou
pour certains sujets qui vont toucher à
ce qu'on appelle les intérêts vitaux et
oui ça fait partie des grandes questions
des grands enjeux que l'on peut avoir et
qui sont au cas particulier concernant
la défense mais fortement en avant
depuis un an alors c'est assez difficile
on a cherché pardon je vais donner juste
cette info sur ce qu'on a livré sur la
France à livrer à l'Ukraine évidemment
il y a pas de communication officielle
donc on a fait une compilation
différents articles de presse on arrive
à ces chiffres une trentaine de canons
dont 18 Césars des missiles en T-shirt
de lait où sont des lance-roquettes des
engins blasés équipés de canons donner
de trinquants
c'est quoi
la France disposait de 13 et les rues et
en pot de fleur tu le sert plus et on
dispose de 8lrue en état et on en a
envoyé deux trois en Ukraine je sais
plus et donc il nous en reste à peu près
4 ou 5 pour toute l'armée française ça
veut dire qu'on peut plus livrer grand
chose 2030 non alors il se trouve que
j'ai été auditionné par la commission
qui parlait des munitions
il faut bien voir que c'est pas c'est
pas un système simple en disant des
munitions non c'est plein de
sous-ensembles en fait et le problème
c'est d'avoir la
le contrôle de la chaîne complète des
sous-ensemble c'est là où je parlais
tout à l'heure de sous-ensemble qui sont
fabriqués au Pakistan parce qu'on ne
peut pas les fabriquer en France par
exemple donc c'est très important
d'avoir cette chaîne complète deuxième
ou l'importance de relocaliser la
production de poudre je reviens à cette
info donc par exemple
et le deuxième point c'est que on était
pendant toute cette période des
dividendes de la paix dans un flux tendu
comme les industries on disait
finalement on va faire pareil un flux
tendu et pas dans un une logique de
stock or maintenant on s'aperçoit que il
faut des stocks parce qu'il faut faire
tant de tampon avant que la production
elle ne puisse recompléter les
Américains ont le même problème à une
échelle qui n'a rien à voir avec la
nôtre mais elles ont le même problème
mais qui prend le risque pour
reconstituer c'est l'entreprise ou c'est
l'État qui donne c'est l'État qui donne
la commande c'est que les entreprises
doivent avoir des commandes d'État sinon
c'est ton problème de l'économie de
guerre que dont parlait le manuel Macron
qu'on dont on parle d'ailleurs dans ce
rapport sur un an de guerre en Ukraine
et où on dit que les monts un sens et
qu'il faut être prudent parce qu'on
n'est pas en guerre d'abord et que
économie de guerre ça suppose en tout
cas si on reprend ce qui s'est passé
dans la deuxième guerre mondiale ça
suppose quand même des nationalisations
des mesures très très coercitives
aujourd'hui l'économie de guerre telle
qu'elle est prévue ou en tout cas à
expliquer c'est une accélération des
processus de production mais évidemment
c'est ce que disent toutes les
entreprises pour accélérer les processus
de production encore faut-il avoir des
commandes et nous ce qu'on met en avant
dans ce rapport c'est que depuis un an
ben en fait on a perdu un an puisque
quasiment aucune commande nouvelle n'ont
été mises en oeuvre en dehors de celle
qui était prévue dans la loi de
programmation militaire dernière enfin
en cours mais et là il y a une vraie il
y a une vraie problématique mais là il y
a la nouvelle loi alors elle est pas
votée elle va passer évidemment au Sénat
au à l'Assemblée les 400 alors 413 j'ai
lu 40030 milliards pour moi si c'était
413 milliards il fallait dire 413
milliards là c'est 400 + 13 dont 13 de
recettes incertaine qui sont liées à des
ventes immobilières de fréquences je dis
pas que c'est pas assez je reconnais que
c'est un effort considé les problèmes
n'est pas là le problème c'est pour moi
que débat d'abord on est dans une
inflation qui est quasiment de 6%, ça
fait peu près 7 milliards par an sur
l'augmentation du budget annuel ça fait
7 milliards de qui ont mangé par
l'inflation donc déjà c'est quand même
pas une paille comme on dit on a ces 13
milliards qui sont des recettes
incertaine qui représentent à peu près
sur l'ensemble de la loi de
programmation militaire 2 milliards par
an et donc derrière tout ça c'est quelle
stratégie on veut mettre en place avec
quel budget un mot là-dessus très vite
l'industrie française joue à la fois sur
la commande nationale mais sur l'export
un exemple le César deux fois plus de
César exporté que de ça César compris en
France et ça ce sont des contrats qui
vont faire fonctionner aussi l'industrie
donc il faut des commandes de l'État
bien sûr mais il faut aussi des
matériels exportables parce que ça
multiplie le nombre de engins et ça
facilite bien sûr l'industrialisation
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat évidemment il y
avait encore beaucoup beaucoup de thèmes
à aborder mais on en a déjà balayé pas
mal merci encore je vous dis à demain
pour un nouveau numéro de ce sens public
et puis votre prochain rendez-vous
politique dans la matinale c'est
Jean-Louis bourlange président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de
l'Assemblée invité Doriane Mancini il
sera 8h du matin belle soirée
[Musique]